CUOMO, SO WHEN HE ALL OF A
SUDDEN STARTED SAYING I WANT TO
DO SOMETHING FOR NEW YORK --
NEW YORKERS ARE NEW YORK TOUGH
AND I DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO LET
EVERYONE GO THROUGH AN
IMPEACHMENT, I RESIGN.
I WAS SURPRISED.
>> Greg: WHAT WAS THE RESPONSE
FROM HIS OFFICE?
WAS IT A TWEET?
WHAT DID THEY SAY TO YOU THAT
KIND OF LIKE INSULTED YOU AT THE
START OF THIS?
>> RIGHT.
IT WAS A COLUMN I THINK IN THE
DAILY MAIL WHERE THEY GOT RICH
AS A PARTY, WHICH IS ONE OF HIS,
YOU KNOW, TOP -- I CALL THEM THE
TROLL, THE TROLL DOGS WHO SAID
SHE IS NOT A RELIABLE SOURCE IN
ANYTHING EXCEPT THE WEATHER.
I THINK I FORECAST OF SOME
PRETTY GOOD AND IT WAS A
LONG-RANGE FORECAST.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: OF GOT ONE MORE
QUESTION FOR YOU BEFORE WE GO.
I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE ON
"HANNITY" AND I'M GOING TO BE
WATCHING.
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL CUOMO IF YOU
SAW HIM RIGHT NOW?
>> I DON'T EVER WANT TO SEE
HIS -- I ACTUALLY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE HIM IN HANDCUFFS BEFORE I
SEE HIM IN PERSON, HOW ABOUT
THAT?
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU, JANICE,
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU ARE ONE
TOUGH BROAD!
A HERO!
>> LOVE YOU GUYS!
>> Greg: SEE YOU LATER, SEE
YOU SOON.
>> THANK YOU!
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, KATIE,
WHAT ABOUT THIS COVID NURSING
HOME STUFF?
ARE THE ACTUALLY GOING TO FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH THAT WHEN THERE ARE
POLITICIANS INVOLVED?
>> THERE ARE SOME DEMOCRATS AND
THE NEW YORK STATE LEGISLATURE
WHO SAY THAT THEY WANT TO BUT
HAVE A FEELING THAT THEY WILL
NOT AND I THINK THAT THE
RESIGNATION TODAY WAS MORE ABOUT
PROTECTING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THEN IT WAS ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
SAYING I'M SORRY FOR SEXUALLY
HARASSING 11 OF THESE WOMEN WITH
THE REPORT AND I LET EVERYBODY
DOWN BASED ON WHAT HE SAID AND
THE REASON I THINK THAT IS
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS IN
NEW YORK DIDN'T HAVE TO IMPEACH
THEM, THEY GET TO WALK AWAY FROM
THAT, HE GETS TO GO AND MOVE ON
WITH HIS $5 MILLION THAT HE GOT
WITH HIS BOOK DEAL AND THEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN DIDN'T HAVE TO
HAVE TO ASK DOJ TO LAUNCH A
CIVIL RIGHTS INVESTIGATION AND
THEY ALREADY GOT RID OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS INVESTIGATION INTO
NURSING HOMES AND IT'S EASIER
FOR DEMOCRATS NOW BECAUSE A
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR IN
NEW JERSEY, DEMOCRAT GOVERNOR IN
MICHIGAN.
OTHER DEMOCRATS AROUND THE
COUNTRY ALSO SIGNED SIMILAR
ORDERS IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DOESN'T WANT THIS BIG
INVESTIGATION OF THE PARTY AS A
WHOLE ON THE STATE LEVEL OF THE
COVID -- AND MORE SERIOUS,
PEOPLE DIED, SO IT'S NOT THAT
THIS DOESN'T MATTER, I'M JUST
CYNICAL ABOUT THE INTENTIONS
HERE.
>> Greg: KAT, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> I WAS JUST THINKING ABOUT HOW
A FEW MONTHS AGO WHEN HE HAD THE
RINGS OUT --
>> Greg: YES.
>> HE WASN'T EVEN WEARING A BRA.
YOU COULD SEE THE RINGS DURING A
PRESS CONFERENCE AND I DEFENDED
THAT, I SAID I DON'T WANT TO
KINK SHAME.
ALL OF OUR VIEWERS WHO HAVE
RINGS, I STAND WITH YOU.
I STAND BY THAT.
WHAT I DID NOT KNOW WAS THAT HIS
RING DISPLAY WAS ACTUALLY THE
LEAST OFFENSIVE THING ABOUT HIM
BY FAR, WHICH IS RARE TO SAY
ABOUT SOMEONE WITH NIPPLE RINGS.
>> Greg: EXACTLY BURIED
>> USUALLY, YOU KNOW --
>> Greg: NIPPLE RINGS CAN
OFTEN BE A CRY FOR HELP,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU PULL ON
THEM.
TYRUS.
>> FEEL FREE TO PIGGYBACK OFF OF
MY POINT!
>> YOU KNOW I CAN'T PIGGYBACK.
YOUR LITTLE LEGS WOULD
JUST -- --
>> MURDER.
>> I THINK IT'S FUNNY WHEN WE
SEE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THEY
APPOINT THESE HEROES.
CNN'S RECORD IS GETTING PRETTY
BAD.
YOU'VE GOT THE MICHAEL AVENATTI
HERO.
HE WAS ROBBING HANDICAPPED KIDS
AND THEN YOU'VE GOT CUOMO WHO IS
GIVING THE ICEMAN A RUN FOR
MONEY IS A SERIAL KILLER WITH
OLD FOLKS, BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FOR US ALL TO
REMEMBER IS HIS ONLY CRIME IS
THAT HE LOVES TOO MUCH.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> HE'S ACTUALLY THE SECOND MAN
WITH NIPPLE RINGS TO LIE TO ME.
>> Greg: WHY DO YOU KEEP --
WELL.
IT WASN'T ALIVE
>> IT'S JUST AMAZING TO ME THAT
HE -- EVEN WITH THE
INVESTIGATION, BECAUSE WE ALL
KNOW YOU MUST RESPECT THE
INVESTIGATION.
THE INVESTIGATION IS EVERYTHING
IN THE INVESTIGATION DIDN'T SAY
HE DID IT SIX TIMES OR FOUR
TIMES, WHICH IS STILL BAD.
>> Greg: HE DID 11.
>> HE SCORED 100% ON AN
INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S NOT IN.
HE FAILED MISERABLY, HE
RESIGNED.
WHAT DOES HE NEED TWO WEEKS FOR?
HE'S DIVORCED, NONE OF THE KIDS
LIVE IN THE MANSION, HE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO LEAVE IN A HALF-HOUR.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE TO PLAN A
GOING AWAY PARTY.
>> I WOULDN'T PUT IT PAST HIM OR
HE HAS A CHANGE OF HEART AND THE
OUTCRY FROM BROKENHEARTED
SUPPORTERS EVERYWHERE SAY STAY
IN THERE AND FIGHT.
>> Greg: MY THOUGHT, HE SHOULD
RUN FOR NEW YORK MAYOR.
YES.
JOE, WHAT COULD YOU BE THINKING?
>> ALLOTS GOING THROUGH MY HEAD
RIGHT NOW.
FIRST OFF, I THOUGHT THAT LINE
ABOUT THE FRANKENSTEIN MONSTER
WEARING THE JACKET DESERVED A
LITTLE MORE, TO BE QUITE HONEST.
A >> Greg: I AGREE!
BECAUSE IF YOU REMEMBER
FRANKENSTEIN, WHY IS HE WEARING
A SPORT COAT?
>> HE WAS THE FIRST HIPSTER WITH
A SPORTS COAT, THE BAD
HAIRCUT --
>> Greg: IT WAS A COLLARED
SHIRT!
>> HOW DARE YOU BOTH BURIED
FRANKENSTEIN WAS 6'10", HE
DIDN'T HAVE MUCH CHOICE IN
CLOTHES THAT DAY, IT WAS LIKE
JACKET OR COW HIDE.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
I'M A LITTLE LEERY ABOUT A
POLITICIAN SAYS SOMETHING IS
GOING TO END IN TWO WEEKS.
THE OTHER THING THAT IT MADE ME
THINK IS I THINK NEW YORK
PROBABLY MRS. ELIOT SPITZER AT
THIS POINT.
ALL THAT GUY DID WAS SLEEP WITH
PROSTITUTES AND THAT LOOKS
PRETTY GOOD TO ME.
OF HAVING A GOVERNOR --
>> YOU'VE GOT NO
[INDISCERNIBLE].
>> THAT'S GOING TO BE TAKEN OUT
OF CONTEXT.
>> Greg: SOME GUIDANCE
COUNSELOR YOU ARE BURIED HIM
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED IT?
WHY ARE YOU WEARING A JACKET?
ANYWAY.
UP NEXT,